[Música]
beatriz vélez académica y socio
antropóloga del fútbol bienvenida a
radio canadá internacional
hola pablo qué gusto estar aquí contigo
y con la gente que nos estaba viendo y
escuchando las escucha viendo decía uno
de nuestros uno de nuestros oyentes en
colombia en bogotá cuando sacamos los
primeros programas por vídeo entonces él
nos decía que si él ahora no estábamos
escuchando y si no escucha viendo es un
nuevo biológico para esta nueva forma de
comunicar
beatriz tú escribiste un artículo sobre
el coronavirus
de hecho has escrito varios artículos
pero hay uno que escribiste sobre el
coronavirus y el fútbol y tanto en el
uno como en el otro existe un miedo
particular al contacto con las manos con
cómo podemos comprender este miedo
pues esa es la gran pregunta pablo que
yo me he formulado y que todavía no he
podido responder plenamente pero
efectivamente en lo que a mí me atrajo
más en la investigación sobre el fútbol
es el hecho de que es el único deporte
el único óigase el único que prohíbe que
prescribe utilizar el pie y prohíbe
utilizar las manos para controlar un
balón redondo que cabría verdaderamente
en el cuenco de las manos entonces eso
es una gran paradoja desde el punto de
vista antropológico y ahí es donde yo me
he detenido a preguntarme es miedo o es
justamente lo contrario es una audacia
porque al no usar las manos y pretender
que los pies sustituyan las manos en el
control de ese balón lo que se está
buscando es ampliar el universo vital el
mundo vital corre a las paredes de
nuestros límites que es muy propio de
los humanos entonces desde ese punto de
vista
el fútbol es un hecho tropo lógico de
una potencia indudable y bueno si
comparamos a un terreno de fútbol con
por ejemplo una cancha de básquetbol
donde se utiliza mucho las manos el
terreno de fútbol es muchísimo más
grande exactamente entonces el desafío
es todavía mayor porque primero lo más
natural digamos sí a menudo se dice que
los un pues que por naturaleza tal cosa
de los manos en verdaderamente los
humanos se dicen antropología somos y
naturales por naturaleza esto es otra
gran paradoja es decir nosotros somos
seres de paradojas entonces al decir que
somos sin naturales por naturaleza lo
que estamos sugiriendo es que nos gusta
poner en paréntesis el control y el
dominio que tiene la naturaleza sobre
nosotros en la medida en que somos seres
vivos para hacer cosas que nos con las
que pretendemos de alguna manera ser
autónomo sobre la naturaleza y casi
decirle a la naturaleza
usted no nos determina y un poco tratar
de imitar a los dioses entonces y desde
el punto de vista antropológico es muy
hermoso
y es creo uno de los muy raros deportes
en los que las manos están prescritas el
fútbol yo creo que es el único pablo en
la lista que yo tengo no hay ninguno
conocido por lo menos cierto puede que
en algunas comunidades existan
prohibiciones de ese tipo también pero
en antropología se dice también en las
prohibiciones porque las manos tienen
son comparables a un segundo cerebro es
decir la ductilidad el conocimiento la
habilidad la destreza manual son cosas
absolutamente
y limitadas cierto e inéditas es decir
la competencia que tiene las manos que
tienen las manos para hacer cosas que
nos pueden llevar digamos a lo más
sublime o nos pueden llevar lo más
abyecto son
el espacio es tan enorme tan enorme que
eso termina siendo una gran pregunta
para los humanos cierto entonces es el
poder de las manos termina siendo como
una suerte de amenaza también para en el
imaginario digámoslo así de los pueblos
y de los individuos y por eso las manos
por su capacidad de ser digamos
dúctiles ideas de hacer cosas que muy a
menudo no controlamos
por eso el refrán yo lo digo en el
artículo se me fueron las manos ciertos
como si las manos gozarán de una suerte
de autonomía del individuo que las porta
es cierto entonces eso hace que ellas
sean verdaderamente un instrumento tan
completamente cierto como el propio
cerebro al que el sujeto en su pequeñez
digamos las diferencias las dos
potencias será muy limitado y muy
amedrentado
digámoslo correctamente cierto bueno y
bueno las manos permitieron la evolución
del ser humano o sea a partir del
momento en que el mono se bajó del árbol
y se empezó a caminar recto pues las
manos permitieron que llegáramos a lo
que somos hoy claro y fíjate que la
ductilidad de las manos y el
conocimiento es decir las manos psuv
como un vector de conocimiento porque
las manos nos permiten por ejemplo
tocando y el tocar es uno de los
sentidos digamos más importantes y
también más perseguidos porque el tocar
es peligroso cierto entonces
es una fuente de conocimiento que se
hace en todo a través de las manos
porque cuando tú tocas por ejemplo una
superficie yo lo hago a menudo con
algunos algunas niñas y niños que
encuentro en mi camino los invito a que
todo que por ejemplo superficies blandas
y superficies duras superficies frías y
superficies calientes y tú ves en sus
ojos con una revelación digamos del
mundo cierto entonces cuando tú tocas
también la piel
eso es una revelación absolutamente
fantástica de ver toda la potencia que
es como si hubieras hubiese ojos en las
puntas de los dedos cierto entonces esa
sensibilidad tan absolutamente
desproporcionada que tienen las manos lo
hacen como yo te digo o los órganos tan
dúctiles y tan potentes como el cerebro
mismo
si beatriz tú también establece una
relación entre el contacto móvil 19 y el
contagio mimético en el fútbol como se
establece de relación
es decir es decir la categoría digamos
que los asocia a uno ya otra es el
contagio el contagio es una cosa de la
que tú tienes miedo porque porque piensa
en el caso del coronavirus es un
vehículo o un vector de peligro si auto
enfermedad de muerte de muerte incluso
cierto en el caso por ejemplo del
contagio mimético ahí es un placer es
cierto y nosotros como como magnus
miméticos es decir aprendemos a través
de limitación cierto pero ese es un
contagio cuando una persona niño ríe o
una niña ríen los dos otros niños se
ponen a reír cierto y los adultos
también y hay como una suerte de
contagio emotivo en el fútbol y
condiciona mucho esa cuestión del
contagio emotivo entonces eso trae
también un elemento muy importante para
el análisis del fútbol desde el punto de
vista antropológico y es el hecho de la
presencia del otro es decir es un
escenario de vivo el fútbol puede
compararse digamos a un s en arriba por
qué
el espectáculo o el partido se va
desarrollando delante de tus ojos y
aunque los jugadores se hayan preparado
previamente para afrontar digamos al
adversario van a sucederse millones de
situaciones y que no estaban previstas
cierto porque es que el libreto se va
desarrollando a medida que se va
haciendo entonces una es una performance
y en esa medida los actos inusitados es
lo que el espectador finalmente tiende a
buscar aciertos esas cosas que surgen en
sí como pues es exactamente no de la
magia y exactamente no de la
aleatoriedad pero un poco resultado
también de seat aleatoriedad es decir
que falla uno de los jugadores en su
defensa o que el ataque es más más
rápido de lo que uno pensaba entonces
eso es lo que hace esa vitalidad y ese
movimiento y ese cambio permanente del
fútbol es lo que lo hace un espectáculo
tan absolutamente fascinante que
igualmente pues coincide con otros
espectáculos duro nombradas de
deportivos como el basket pero en el
caso del fútbol por la dificultad de
adicionar
y las proezas se están arrancando es a
través de él la mayoría con los pies y
con un valor completamente en redondo
siento es que eso se vuelve desde el
punto de vista simbólico como de una
gran potencia y de un gran valor
antropológico y humano cierto por eso es
que yo en la antropología del fútbol me
he quedado desde hace tanto tiempo
analizándolo porque tú te das cuenta
pablo de la riqueza que encierra el
fútbol que aparentemente es como tan
banal el exacto justamente hablando de
la riqueza del fútbol beatriz más allá
de el coronavirus también has descrito
sobre la connotación sexual del fútbol
como cómo se caracteriza esta
connotación sexual bueno ese es otro
tema que está muy ligado también al
valor antropológico que tiene el fútbol
porque finalmente la sexualidad de lo
que nos pone de frente es la importancia
de la corporeidad hacia nosotros vivimos
en occidente en sociedades que son
profundamente
adversas digamos a la carnalidad en
parte pues mucho por las religiones el
cristianismo colocó en su momento y
otras religiones han seguido siendo pues
digamos groseras como de esa persecución
y ese miedo porque es un miedo
finalmente a la potencia que tiene el
cuerpo entonces occidente ha consagrado
mucho la distancia entre la mente y el
poder es cierto y en el caso del fútbol
para ser un elemento o un elemento no
una actuación donde el vector del de la
acción es el cuerpo pues obviamente que
los fantasmas digamos que el cuerpo y la
materia viva y ese cuerpo autónomo y ese
cuerpo que es portador digamos de
emociones y de deseos y de sensaciones
pues aparecen aparecen ahí porque además
el fútbol tiene esa belleza particular
también que no tiene mucha utilería
cierto no es como por ejemplo en hockey
que está que son el cuerpo no se ve
directamente en el fútbol el cuerpo está
prácticamente al desnudo cierto está
vivo está es decir es la pulsión el
movimiento las imágenes corporales la
proeza láser
las actividades corporales todo eso
suscita digamos un imaginario sexual muy
grande cierto y cuando yo empecé a hacer
mis investigaciones pese a que llegó a
la conclusión de que el fútbol es un
juego hecho por hombres y para hombres
en el trabajo de terreno me dicen
algunos que un gol es como un orgasmo
entonces a mí me parecía muy perturbador
que siendo un juego como homofóbico
porque lo es porque son la gran y la
gran mayoría son hombres que se dicen
muy prestantes de su virilidad cierto y
que detestan los temas homosexuales en
los en los cánticos pues digamos de los
hinchas que vemos claramente esto siendo
un juego homofóbico es decir que detesta
a los homosexuales había la idea de un
gol comparable a un orgasmo cierto
entonces era como muy perturbador y yo
me preguntaba pero entonces cuál es el
asunto aquí
y efectivamente haciendo con una
semiótica de los elementos del juego tú
terminas por comprender desde el punto
de vista de una antropología del cuerpo
que el pie es un sí es un equivalente
del falo cierto y que la portería es una
suerte de equivalente de una abertura si
yo lo hablo muy claramente en mi libro y
que el balón finalmente e incluso
apoyándome en frases de eduardo galeano
como que dice que un balón es una pieza
femenina que nunca se maltrata que el
buen crack nunca la patea y apoyándome
también en frases de eric cantona que
dice que un balón es como una mujer
adora las caricias y nunca luego y no
los golpes de pie y todo esto el buen
crack no patea el balón lo acaricie alba
cuya lo mima en lo que dice galeano
entonces todos esos res y todas esas
narraciones sobre el fútbol hechas por
hombres muestran que hay un componente
erótico muy grande y hay libros que lo
muestran hay un libro muy famoso que se
llama fútbol y el fútbol ya el último es
el mío que se llama el erotismo en el
fútbol cierto que es muy interesante
también sobre todas esas figuras pues
digamos del cuerpo y del erotismo en el
fútbol siendo que es un poco menos bueno
muy hermoso ex post homofóbico
homofóbicos pero justamente yo quiero
regresar a este aspecto homofóbico del
fútbol porque ahora también se está
jugando las mujeres están jugando cada
vez más el fútbol hay cambio él está
participando en torneos mundiales el
fútbol femenino está bastante presente
el razonamiento que tú haces se puede
aplicar también al fútbol femenino
pues es decir en las investigaciones que
ha hecho hecho también con mujeres hasta
ahora no podría llegar tan rotundamente
a esta conclusión que seguramente es una
conclusión pues la que yo hago también
con relación a los hombres muy genérica
porque hay hombres que son menos digamos
sensibles a esa idea de una virilidad
agresiva cierto que bien y la idea de
virilidad no es solamente una idea de
virilidad asociada digamos a la
penetración como un arma cierto que es
como un poco el sentido también que hay
la penetración es una suerte de
violación en el fútbol también es una
violación del terreno adverso para
penetrar con el balón el balón penetra
el arco el arco y claramente italiano lo
dice el balón es una menina una redonda
una pieza femenina pero en algún momento
deviene una bala blanca que penetra la
red es cierto entonces esas imágenes
digamos son como tan carnales y tan
eróticas desde el punto de vista de una
masculinidad firmada en ese modelo de la
violencia en el ejercicio de su
sexualidad
tampoco el ágape de muchos hombres
cierto yo después lo que predominen los
cánticos y entre los más fanáticos y es
una está muy claramente asociado en el
sentido popular a eso yo creo que las
mujeres cierto a no ser que entren
digamos en esa misma lógica de esos
hombres que son así que conciben la
sexualidad como una violencia contra la
mujer o contra el otro contra el
homosexual no no van digamos con esa
ideología cierto porque además de que el
fútbol es esto cierto esa penetración es
la violencia también es digamos la
muestra de una técnica y de una
capacidad digamos de ser más bien dúctil
que fuerte cierto la ductilidad y la
fuerza son dos cosas muy diferentes tú
eres más inteligente porque eres dúctil
y muy inteligente porque eres violento
la violencia no es propia de los
individuos inteligentes y la
civilización se ha dicho pablo comienza
en el momento en que en lugar de matar a
tu adversario cierto a la persona que te
hizo algo malo en lugar de matarlo le
lanzas una injuria y un injuv y es un
acto inteligente tan fuerte tan fuerte
que va a quedar
digamos trabajando una cosa iba a buscar
una venganza
perdón
pero trastornado a quedar atrás
exacto y ese de bala es para alimentar
la vida hasta que él busca otra como
hacen por ejemplo en la costa que es un
careo de palabras inteligentes pero si
tú eliminas a tu enemigo a tu adversario
en este caso y lo haces como un enemigo
obviamente que el juego se acaba cierto
entonces la lógica es la de la violencia
del fútbol llevaría que en extremo pues
en el límite terminas es asesinado con
quién y no tienes con quién jugar ser
que es otro elemento que introduce a una
cadena muy linda que la presencia y la
necesidad del otro en el pueblo bueno
que eso era material para otra
conversación más tarde pero está bien
muchas veces se genera por parte del
público cuando terminan los partidos en
la calle y los hinchas se vuelven unos
vándalos pero como te decía eso es
harina de otro costal aunque si es del
mismo pero igual no no tenemos mucho
tiempo para entrar en eso
nadie te dice lo que es la connotación
sexual entonces estaba mucho en él
léxico que se utiliza para describir el
deporte el juego como tal y como yo te
digo pablo esa connotación sexual está
muy afirmada muy se hace un equivalente
más bien de un lenguaje muy agresivo y
muy violento y muy belicistas cierto es
decir porque es eliminar al adversario
cierto es penetrar lo es hacerlo sentir
que no fue lo suficientemente viril o lo
suficientemente fuerte o lo
suficientemente
empoderado digámoslo así para resistir
digamos el ataque adversario como una
mujer cierto entonces en las barras por
ejemplo en lo que tú dicen los
delincuentes por la delincuencia que se
produce después del partido es
generalmente entre individuos que son
muy afectos a esa noción de virilidad de
la violencia es cierto o de la
sexualidad o de la afirmación de los
hombres a través de una afirmación
violenta despectiva del otro es decir a
través del desprecio de categorías que
no son la categoría del respeto la
categoría de la de la cohesión con el
otro de la de la asociación con el otro
sino de la destrucción con el otro que
también tiene digamos expresión en la
política en la economía en muchas
maneras pues de vida de la sociedad
muy interesante beatriz
desafortunadamente el tiempo pasa como
agua entre los dedos
muchísimas gracias por esta entrevista
beatriz vélez se académica y socio
antropóloga del fútbol muchas gracias
gracias a ti pablo y espero pues que sea
útil y que muchas personas de las que
nos están viendo y oyendo comprendan
otras dimensiones ocultas del fútbol que
es lo que lo hace fascinante muchas
gracias
[Música]